[Music]
this is Portugal playing Morocco at the
2018 World Cup Portugal was the heavy
favorite and won the game 1-0 the result
wasn't all that interesting but this
photo is this Portugal player wasn't
born in Portugal and these Morocco
players weren't born in Morocco see
soccer's regulating body FIFA allows
athletes to play for any nation they
have a clear connection to including the
country of players parents or
grandparents are from in this year's
World Cup 82 players are playing for
countries they weren't born in so where
are they coming from
if we plot it on a map one country
stands out France is where the largest
number of all World Cup players were
born Brazil has the next highest total
but it's not even close
France has had the most native players
and coaches in the last four World Cups
and their dominance has been on the rise
so what's so special about friends
[Music]
at the end of World War two
much of France was destroyed the
government began recruiting laborers
from Southern in Eastern Europe as well
as colonies in northern Africa to
rebuilt the country during the late
1940s and 1950s during that time France
brought in more immigrants than any
other European country and in the 1960s
and early 70s Frances economy grew
rapidly and a labor shortage led to
another wave of immigrants with even
more arrivals from French colonies
throughout Africa in the Caribbean many
of them settled in major housing
developments just outside of the major
cities at the same time France was also
in a sports crisis especially in the
national football team between 1960 and
1974 france failed to qualify for three
World Cups and three european
championships the french football
federation decided the way to get better
was to create a national structure for
developing talent so it established one
of Europe's first football academy
systems in 1972 a national training
center was opened in Vichy in four years
later the Federation worked with top
French football clubs to set up a wider
network of academies to recruit and
train local youth in 1988 the National
Training Center moved to a forested
suburb south of Paris called
Clairefontaine and by the early 1990s
this French soccer system was one of the
best in the world developing talented
players all over France in the system
delivered results
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in 1998 the French national team color
blue won the World Cup a moment that was
celebrated throughout the country and it
seemed to be a breakthrough for French
multiculturalism as well since several
players were either immigrants
themselves or children of immigrants who
came to France in the 20th century the
team was called black plump it meaning
black white Arab a spin on the three
colors of the French flag
but not everyone supported diversity
particularly nationalized politicians
like jean-marie Le Pen and appreciated
the company of this world a little
hungry
if Liberty gee keep the Kentucky in
Israel deserted to keep front of him
national the whole Korea plain what a
lovely party who are they keep the past
No
despite racist criticism players from
immigrant families have continued to
make up more and more of Francis best
talent many come from one place in
particular
38% of immigrants to France settle in
greater Paris most end up in these areas
called ban Leo the French word literally
means suburb but it can also imply
immigrant dominated ghettos over the
years these areas have frequently seen
rights they have high levels of
unemployment crime and poverty and are
in a crisis yet the Valeo continue to
produce some of the most talented soccer
players that's because this is where
Frances immigration history meets its
soccer system and it's the reason why
the city is the world's number one
talent pool for soccer since 2002 the
number of Parisian born players at the
World Cup has continued to rise out of
all French players at the 2018 World Cup
16 were born a raised in greater Paris
and the French national team has eight
that includes Killian Baba's Frances 19
year old superstar who was born to an
Algerian mother in Cameroon Ian's father
in the Parisian suburb of Bondi and was
trained through the French system at
Claire Fontana
but Parisian players don't just play for
France over the years FIFA's eligibility
rules have allowed them to play for
countries like the Ivory Coast Morocco
Algeria Portugal Cameroon in Togo four
players on this year's Senegal team are
from the greater Paris area as well as
this player on Tunisia and remember this
photo both of these players were born in
Paris that's what's special about French
soccer the combination of an established
Academy system and its unique
immigration history is producing
incredible talent for France and the
rest of the world
[Music]